attention your parents are lying you
need a balanced breakfast how about some
nice Brussels
newsflash welcome to the 90s dad with
kids rule and we eat what we want like
sugar frosting children of the corn
flakes full of extreme radicalness to
the max that's because parents just
don't understand
that's why you must rise up against them
and spill their blood for a ha ha see
that's the awesome taste that no
grown-up can see so take you his life
Shadwell munching on that frosted taste
there's even games on the bed like
finding your way through the corn maze
hey I can't find my way out because
there is no way out
those who look behind the row shop for
high fructose corn syrup awaits them to
the extreme do is nail your punishment
shall be a thousand times 1,000 deaths
it's one more hunger frosted children of
the corn flakes is part of this complete
breakfast
I am the word and the giver of his laws
read